so show state it's a poignant moment
being the 75th anniversary of the Battle
of Britain the men and women who
performed curare nowadays carry out a
very similar role to their previous essa
75 years ago I wonder whether you could
give us a few words on the parallels
between now and what happened in World
War two
well it's extraordinary think that you
have brave well-trained world-class
pilots doing the same thing now as their
heroic predecessors were doing 75 years
ago
you remember Churchill's famous
quotation never in the field of human
conflict was so much owed by so many to
so few and it is only a few a handful of
world-class pilots flying our typhoons
who keep our skies safe today just as
those Battle of Britain pilots did 75
years ago and now secretary safe defense
you've been to visit the operation at
RAF Lossiemouth what are your thoughts
when you first saw it when you first
went round I hadn't appreciated the the
the fact that these pilots are on duty
every minute every day Christmas Day the
middle of the night to get up there and
defend our skies and we owe them a huge
debt for that they already run the clock
to defend our freedom do you think they
have the resources they need the typhoon
is going to be taken on new roles in a
new multi-role aircraft is there enough
there to defend the skies of Britain we
have the West we have the fifth biggest
defense budget in the world and a lot of
it goes on the Royal Air Force who
really are the frontline there are
tornados as you know our interaction
against I saw out in the Middle East we
have the typhoons defending our skies
and Britain defending the Falklands and
playing a role in NATO and helping to
defend Baltic airspace against the
Russian threat each of the summer months
I was going to ask you about the Russian
threat it's a threat that plays out not
only in the Baltic States but also close
to the skies in the United Kingdom how
do you assess that as a current threat
well it's a serious threat it's not a
game we have to respond to it Russia is
testing our defenses and the defenses of
other NATO members and it's very
important that we respond and it's
important we make sure that skies are
kept clear of any intrusion that Russian
aircraft are kept outside UK airspace
and it's also important that we make
sure that if Russian planes come to the
edge of our airspace that there isn't
disruption to commercial air travel
strictly speaking they're not doing
anything illegal because they're staying
within international airspace but when
you have events such as the time they
flew up the English Channel they are
going as you say into very busy
commercial airspace is there any more
pressure that we put on Moscow to avoid
such scenarios well we continue to point
out that this kind of flying is is
extremely intimidating it's not so
dangerous they may not enter our
airspace but they don't respond they
don't file flight plans they don't
respond to air traffic control they
don't even respond to our pilots when
they're up in the air are alongside them
them and occasionally it means that
civil air airliners have to be diverted
from their normal routes and there is
disruption from that so it's it's
unnecessary behavior it's intimidatory
it's designed to to annoy us but it's
important we respond to it and we do
does it annoy you it's unnecessary
intimidatory it's something we could do
without but we have the RAF there we
have world-class pilots they already run
the clock to respond we have to defend
our airspace just as we have to defend
our Coast and our seas it is something
they've been doing for decades though
relatively speaking it is a known threat
the unknown threat is the passenger
aircraft that might be coming in with
terrorists on board how does the country
prepare to deal with a potential
situation such as that well that's been
a new threat ever since the twin towers
they take on the twin towers in 911 and
don't let's forget that some 67 Britons
lost their lives in that
and we can never discount the
possibility that a terrorist may again
use an aircraft as a kind of flying bomb
to kill huge numbers of people on the
ground so this is a new threat but again
our pilots are ready to respond to that
as well what is your role in QRA well
I'm alerted every time the planes come
up won't return there is an inert
Russian Czars coming towards our
airspace
obviously I'm alerted if there's an
unidentified commercial aircraft then we
have well-worn procedures we plan for
every kind of scenario and in the end
the prime minister or a very senior
minister myself or one of my colleagues
will be will be available to deal with
that particular threat and how does that
play out how are you contacted well in
reality in the minister on duty that day
usually the Prime Minister but
occasionally one of his one of the
senior ministers who takes
responsibility for this will be alerted
and will exercise ministerial control
over the response and will be given
advice but also be put in touch with the
controllers to understand where our
planes are what warnings have been given
and what the response is from the
unidentified area and then there has to
be an assessment made of just what the
threat is how dangerous this incursion
is and what the potential target might
be and you practice this yes we rehearse
these different scenarios we have had
identified aircraft coming into our
airspace failing to file Acula the
proper plan for example or to respond to
air traffic control time and again it
turns out to be to be harmless simply to
be a mistake but you never know and you
can't discount the possibility that one
day a terrorist may use a plane as a
flying bomb may hijack a plane place a
bomb on it and you have to be prepared
if necessary to prevent that plane
reaching its target which means you
might have to make the call to
down in the end you might have to take
the toughest decision of all to protect
the public by authorizing a strike but
you hope of course then it doesn't come
to that and there are a number of other
ways in which you can warn off that
particular aircraft and try and get a
response from it you prepared for that
responsibility you have to be prepared
in the end to protect the public that is
part of part of defence defence does
involve responsibility you have to be
prepared our troops our airmen as soon
as they have to be prepared to to fire
to respond when when danger threatens so
you can't run away from that
responsibility of course you hope you
never ever have to do such a thing as
for example shooting down a civilian
airliner but we know that an honest have
been used as flying bombs before in the
attack on the Twin Towers and we have to
be able to respond now we have
well-worked scenarios our pilots are
very well trained to get up there as
quickly as possible try and establish
contact with this mysterious airliner
and work out whether it is a threat or
whether it isn't but in the end that
decision has to be taken by the Prime
Minister or one of my colleagues and I
imagine when the phone rings even during
an exercise the heart beats a little
faster yes you know there are there are
lives at stake there are uncertainties
you're unsure as to whether I real the
threat is and there's advice available
to you but in the end Minister has to
take that decision